Vegas was fun dude I get why people love
Vegas I don't even drink I didn't even
gamble had fun this pisses me off so
much why we've done so many awesome
things together and then you go to Vegas
and you're like dude this place is fun
yeah being alone is the best that's for
sure that we know I love being alone
God damn did you just Flinch bro shut up
shut the [__] up and watch the goddamn
[__]
oh Derek posting yo shout out to post
and he's the greatest nobody else wants
the gun everybody was scared what do you
mean everybody everybody's like I don't
I don't know the Tushar didn't want to
shoot posting didn't want to shoot and
then Kevin was like I'm a film that's
why he has fun this is the this is the
first time
you're gonna go to the gun range in the
controlled environment and shoot the
pistols I am a risk taker